[Music]
hey everyone welcome to the uplift we've
got a great show for you a great cast of
characters as well and as always of
course including a bakery owner who says
baking helped her get through some very
tough times now she's using her business
to help others we like that here also a
man who received a message from a
stranger that helped connect him to his
own past what did that stranger find out
we are gonna get into it also a 12 year
old who got a lucky draw to become a
ball boy at this year's Dallas open and
that is not the only thing
he did to overcome the odds we'll
explain plus three women from New
Orleans who made history in 1960 they
were just six years old at the time what
are these unsung heroes do we will tell
you that is coming up you're watching
The Uplift we appreciate it
[Music]
hello there I'm Toyota and this is the
uplift the show that lifts you up for at
least the next 30 minutes you and me as
well and we're going to begin with a kid
named Brody who started learning how to
skateboard at just 19 months of age and
now he's gone viral on Tick Tock for
those skateboarding skills here's CBS
Sacramento's Brady halblive
foreign
this is Brody he's four years old he's
been skating with his dad Shane since he
was 19 months old and still wearing
diapers
he's had a lot of practice going to the
skate park nearly every day
and since picking up the sport his
ability on the skateboard is shocking
people around the world
I'm gonna do the Vlog right up to the
Ollie off it all started during the
pandemic Brody's father Shane a local
bartender had a lot of free time on his
hands after a covid-19 shut down
restaurants so he and Brody spent much
of their time here at Granite Regional
skate park
he's now started to uh work on YouTube
Instagram Tick Tock Facebook and we now
have 1.5 million followers worldwide
with the help of Brody's 12 year old
sister Sienna Shane and Brody started
filming their skate sessions and posting
them to tick tock it didn't take long
for people to take notice in less than
12 hours their first video received more
than half a million views it really came
out of nowhere filming these extreme
tricks do come with risks that's why
Shane makes sure safety is top priority
it is scary you know we're involved with
an extreme sport and there's always that
caution just try to be as careful as we
can
Shane says he's trying to be the father
that he never had using skating to teach
Brody important life lessons like when
you fall get right back up and try again
yeah
keep going never giving up for Shane's
skateboarding is not about Brody's
future as a professional or the
followers he says it's about something
much more important we're seeking
happiness
that's what I want to see Smiles
happiness whatever comes with that so
we're trying to make the biggest
positive impact that we can in this life
that's our best trick and they are
landing it so far to our next story for
now though about a teaching Kitchen in
Northern California that's a kitchen
where you learn to cook some students
may think they'll never cook again but
this class aims to prove them wrong
here's CBS Sacramento's Molly real
people often think that if they start
losing their Vision they can't do work
in the kitchen and people discover when
we work with them that they can feel
their independence and their confidence
Dan O'Connor is a mentor and volunteer
at the society for the blinds teaching
kitchen even though he lost his vision
at Birth Dan never shied away from The
Culinary World working 40 years as a
baker but there was something missing
and I realized I wanted to work with my
hand now he's Sharing The Joy of Cooking
with others how to make use of the tools
in the kitchen how to not be intimidated
because they are losing their sight or
they lost their sight the teaching kids
is part of the society for the blind's
senior impact project which offers free
services and classes for those 55 and
older we want them to be confident we
want them to have the tools and the
skills to remain independent Deborah
Pendleton teaches Independent Living
skills including cooking lessons each
class has a skill set the first class is
the knife safety how to safety safely
use a knife how you know where the sharp
edge of a knife is measuring pouring
liquids cleaning many skills those with
vision often take for granted that's
another thing we have to teach is
labeling how you would know what
something was in the refrigerator or in
your cabinet I heard somebody made some
cayenne toast they thought it was
cinnamon it's here that these students
slice and dice their way to confidence
so I can go in the kitchen and do what I
want when I want without waiting for
anyone in the house to help me knowing
that losing one's Vision doesn't have to
mean losing Independence I like to come
here and I ever too old to learn
anything so this is my other home
cooking is empowering stuff we're going
to move on now to those heartwarming
videos the ones you just have to see and
our first one comes from a fashion
designer named Julia who says her
grandmother went to design school back
in the 1940s but dropped out well Julia
found some of her grandmother's old
sketches and decided to turn them into
real life dresses
here's her grandmother's reaction
because I never expected to see any of
them in real life I really didn't
and here they are you
so well I have to say this is quite
uh it's it's as if you've taken a giant
step each time when you're doing it it's
as if you suddenly get some kind of
fashion juices going and you come up
with even more good ideas
and I thank you because that's just
lovely and it and it feels so nice to
see something that I I drew so many many
years ago put it away never thought to
see it again except once in a while
maybe look at it and think oh yeah
that's what I did when I was much much
much younger
oh it's very sweet stuff all right
coming up more very sweet stuff this man
received a message from a stranger soon
realized that he had made a jaw dropping
discovery about his past what was it
we'll tell you
plus meet a boy who was chosen to work
at the Dallas open Beat the odds to get
the job but the challenges he's overcome
off the court are what make him so
inspiring
foreign
[Music]
Sacramento man who received a message
from a stranger a message completely out
of the blue and he soon realized that
this stranger could help him connect
with his past here CBS Sacramento's
Steve large you see those things on TV
you don't really think it's going to
happen to you right Ismail Barba has the
ring back in his hands now the and for
Nogales High School his alma mater it
feels great it feels like a little piece
of me that got lost so many years ago
came back it was two decades ago Barba
gave this class ring to his future
husband Pete Brown he was always the
life of the party the new commitment
ring disappeared when the pair took a
trip to Lake Tahoe in 1999 the ring
vanished on a boat trip we thought you
know what it probably landed at the
bottom of the lake years and decades
passed Barbara wondered about the ring
you know you think about it the pair got
married then a devastating diagnosis
cancer Brown fought it for a year and
unfortunately we lost the battle in May
of last year as Barba continues to
process the loss of a spouse he is now
reveling in a surprise I got a private
message
and it was someone I didn't know asking
are you Ismael that went to Nogales High
School
that lost a ring on a boat in Lake Tahoe
and my jaw dropped take me back to 1999
do you remember being in Lake Tahoe I do
actually Jorge Flores sent that message
to Barba he and his wife had found the
ring on a boat in 1999 and tried finding
the owner initially you know in that
time there wasn't really
many ways to find people you know a
phone book maybe I could not believe
that the ring
had surfaced
literally lost and found and reunited
with a ring his partner wore to show a
commitment that feels more powerful now
than ever before finding the ring really
makes me feel that although Pete's no
longer with me anymore
he's still with me
it's a beautiful story and we're going
to move on though for now the ball girls
and boys at tennis matches are not
supposed to be the focal point on the
court but there is one 12 year old who
got to be a ball boy at the Dallas open
and he deserves the spotlight so let's
give it to him here's J.D miles with the
story
more work than people would think
grabbing catching tossing get the balls
and make sure that the server has enough
and a lot of running because gotta watch
the ball all the time and watch the
server all the time some of the most
physically demanding work in Pro Sports
doesn't involve pro athletes ball boys
and girls chosen to work the Dallas open
are selected for their skills and not
expected to be noticeable or stand out
but it's impossible not to notice Isaac
young if you know his story I think it's
really fun it means a lot it's like it's
kind of like a in a way sometimes it's a
lucky draw like you're lucky to
um be a ball boy it's one of the few
lucky draws in the short life of this
exceptional 12 year old from Allen Who
has fought off cancer not once but twice
his latest bout lasted three years I was
really sick and tired all the time and
then I just had to stay in bed a lot he
is one of the most strong humble
compassionate kids he fought a hard
battle he had a lot of
a lot of hard days a lot of nights in
the hospital Isaac's mom proudly sat
Courtside this week while her son who
was adopted by his foster parents at age
five showed just how far he's come
huge blessing
lots of the years of
being stuck at home and
not getting to do things like this
and so any chance that we get to give
him an opportunity like this we try and
jump on it Isaac isn't just a ball kid
he's also a Super Champ junior tennis
player with dreams of becoming a pro and
competing here at the Dallas open one
day
I think one of my
dreams is maybe being professional
tennis player or basketball player Isaac
who serves as an ambassador for
Children's Health actually got to hit a
few balls with one of the pros on the
stadium Court let's make some noise for
Isaac let's make sure he feels
that's just one of the highlights from a
week that gave Isaac a chance to try and
catch up with other kids's age on Lucky
breaks in life I'm really glad they let
me thank you and one of my greatest
experiences
[Applause]
gratitude Pay It Forward appreciate that
all right stay with us because coming up
the bakery owner who gained attention
for her hiring policy what is that
hiring policy we will tell you plus
meet three unsung heroes who made
history at the tender age of six six
years old
[Music]
Janie Deegan started her Bakery because
baking had helped her out of a dark
place well now helping others is part of
her business model you could say here's
Caitlin O'Kane with the story
nestled in a cozy storefront in East
Harlem New York there's a bakery called
Janie's life-changing baked goods the
most interesting thing on the menu is
their signature pie crust cookies really
though the most interesting thing about
Janie's life-changing baked goods is the
woman behind it Janie who struggled with
homelessness and addiction as a young
woman until baking changed her life
and when I was getting sober I found
that my life was so like out of control
that but baking is such a like you have
to follow all the steps do it all in
order and so baking was just this like
beautiful like meditative very
controlled artistic outlet for me and I
was 25 and had no idea what I wanted to
do with my life but I just found that
baking helped me reconnect with people
Jeannie decided she wanted to open a
bakery but she had gaps in her resume
and something else we just had this
impression that you had to have money to
be a business owner you had to be a man
to be a business owner you had to have
business experience to be a business
owner and so
um it just kind of like I rode the wave
right like I was on a path and like
something led me and um and I had no
idea it would turn into this now Jamie
uses her business to help others
struggling to find a job with mentorship
and second chance employment so we have
an open door hiring policy which means
that you know if you're ready willing
able and like enthusiastic about coming
to work like we're not going to look at
sort of like your past situations or
gaps on your resume or you know if
you're homeless or if you've been in
prison like the person you show up to
the interview as is like the person that
we're looking at she has 15 employees
across two locations in Harlem in the
Upper West Side nearly all of them are
new to the baking business but through
baking she's given them all a second
chance at life I think that like the the
people who do come here like really
value the fact that you don't have to
have like all these credentials or a
background of any sort
to you know to to be invited and
welcomed in and to work with us
sweet it is all right coming up we shed
a light on three Heroes you might not
know about yet but their bravery at just
six years old made history in the Civil
Rights Movement stay with us
sorry is Black History Month and we are
going to highlight three unsung heroes
of the Civil Rights Movement who stuck
bravely together at just six years of
age here is Jamie wax
it was integration day today for the
first grades of two New Orleans
elementary schools it was a short walk
but perhaps one of the most historic
alongside U.S Marshals three little
girls stepping foot into McDonough 19
Elementary in New Orleans to desegregate
schools in the state for the very first
time creating National impact local
police and large numbers were on hand to
see that Integrations took place without
trouble on the morning of November 14
1960 six-year-olds Leona Tate Gail atien
and Tessie Prevost were met by the Roars
of protesters
[Music]
yeah what was your sense as a child
walking past all of that did you know it
was directed to you with the way they
were hollering and making noises I
thought if they could have got to me
they would kill me they were angry with
me and I didn't know why
six years old I didn't understand why
they were acting like that
my daddy told me in the car he said look
straight ahead
take my hand and I'm here
and
I wasn't afraid for some reason I just
wasn't afraid I felt protected with my
daddy and then one by one every single
student left except for the three of you
every single student every single but
the teachers stayed yeah they had
received a telegram that morning telling
them if they didn't report to school
they would be
um no violence but plenty of vocal abuse
for the rest of the year Tate Etienne
and Prevost remained the only students
in the entire School
Ruth Mel Bridges has to go to school but
the media's attention was on first
grader Ruby Bridges who desegregated
William France Elementary School in the
same city on the same day somehow the
world knows Ruby Bridges you were sort
of Forgotten in the in the mix did you
feel that way oh yeah oh yeah you know
because just knowing what we went
through you know and for people not to
remember that was hurtful
they hold no resentment toward Bridges
they forged on but will never forget the
abuse they faced in the other integrated
schools they attended throughout
childhood and at first year I I was on
nerve medicine for a while
as a child as a child at six years old
yes
at SIMS I got hit in the summer with a
baseball bat and the teachers didn't do
anything about it the principal nobody
was like it didn't happen
beat up in the classroom
spit on us
spit now food
in a way there's no possible
ability anyone has to express or or
discuss what you three have shared as a
shared experience I mean that's a very
special bond
my life
their Sisterhood brought them back to
the school
62 years later this time with a new
Mission
the Leona Tate foundation for change
recently purchased the school
transforming the building that's been
vacant since hurricane Katrina into an
educational space that opened just a few
months ago it's called the tep Center a
nod to their three initials we are
sitting here
in the school that the three of you came
to as six-year-olds tell me about
reclaiming this space for what it is now
this summer is to educate those that
didn't know about the the integration
and the desegregation of public schools
and if you feel like you're a part of
that
this is the place you come to try to
solve that problem oh wow this this is
the classroom this is the classroom
visitors can step foot into the original
classroom the girls were confined to in
1960 the only room they were allowed to
sit in this class was full of students
when we got here
but in a matter of few minutes they were
all gone
upstairs the top two floors of the
building have been converted to
apartments for seniors Like Richard
Johnson the first resident to move in
when I come to them doors them glass
doors and I'm inside this is like heaven
this is a spot only this is a special
spot this is special do you feel a sense
of the history of this song trust me I
do is it's like a caterpillar turn into
the cool and then it turned to the
butterfly
that's what happened it's beautiful
this caterpillar of a building has only
grown with time what started as the
center of pain for three little girls
has turned into one of Hope for the
three women today
in fact November 14th has officially
been declared New Orleans four day in
the city recognizing the heroism of all
four Trailblazers whose short walk led
to Lasting change I'll ask each of you
would you do it again if you had to do
it again yes I would
yes all three of you
it made it better it opened up doors
opportunities for other people
you know so somebody had to make the
sacrifice and I guess it was the three
of us
chosen
the chosen ones yes
[Music]
he swings he connects and that is a
grand slam from our Jamie wax and that
is our show I hope it brightens your day
and lifted you up I'm sure that it did
in case it didn't reruns are free I
always say it meantime I'm gonna go find
some more good news
foreign